if you if I'm Jake you know who I fight
next ready for this Robbie Lawler forget
the boxing World dude keep beating up
MMA guys with these huge fan bases
making all the money keep taking out
these great Strikers in the UFC who
cares about getting validated from
boxing they're never going to accept you
ever if you beat Canelo back Ah canode
that's never happening keep making your
money bro and getting these huge fights
against these xufc guys who have huge
fan bases because the MMA Community is
buying this stuff we're a pay-per-view
model we we like buying papers we
support our guys everyone loves Robbie
Lawler everyone loves Nate Diaz people
love Woodley keep doing that if people
love Anderson Silva keep doing that get
your money
keep beating up these non-boxers these
great Strikers
keep doing that
I don't get who gives us about the
internet